ah wells fargo the third largest bank in
the u.s with a total of a 1.78 trillion
dollars in assets under management aside
from being massive in size wells fargo
also has a massive history being founded
nearly 200 years ago in 1852 given their
rich history and dominant position you
would think that wells fargo is one of
the most respected and trusted financial
institutions in the world but this
couldn't be further from the truth
in fact yahoo ranked wells fargo as the
second most hated company in the us in
2020 only beaten up by the weinstein
company for people who don't bank with
wells fargo or follow the financial
industry too closely this might be a bit
surprising but it just takes one glance
at their history to understand why
they're so despised on their wikipedia
page for example their lawsuits fines
and controversy section is literally
longer than their history section so
here's the controversial history of
wells fargo and why they're so dominant
despite all their shortcomings
taking a look back the history of wells
fargo circles back to a man named henry
wells and william fargo these two were
actually co-founders of american express
which was at the time a pretty popular
express company in new york william and
henry wanted to expand american express
to california and leverage the gold rush
but the board opposed this decision
reluctant to give up the idea though the
duo ended up starting wells fargo on
march 18 1852
given their history with express
services wells fargo was also naturally
an express company but they also dabbled
in banking as well
at first things were looking super
bright as depositors flooded in
throughout the early 1850s but it didn't
take long to understand why amex's board
refused to expand to california in 1855
news arrived at the parent company of
the bank paige bacon and company had
collapsed due to overspeculation
this triggered a bank run which quickly
escalated into a statewide banking panic
within just a week customers withdrew so
much money that wells fargo lost one
third of the total assets while this was
disastrous for banks that went under and
customers who couldn't retrieve their
money this actually worked out quite
well for wells fargo
you see wells fargo was one of the few
banks that survived the panic which gave
them two major advantages first of all
wells fargo had very little remaining
competition in california and secondly
surviving the panic gave californians
much more trust and confidence in west
fargo
i'm not sure if this trust was really
deserved though as it didn't take long
for wells fargo to delve into a sketchy
investment wells fargo turned around and
lent these new deposits to a startup
called the overland mail company the
first red flag was the reasoning behind
the loan as it's not clear if the loan
was made based on merit or nepotism
you see the founders of overland mail
had substantial stakes in wells fargo
and american express and the president
of the company was amex's third
co-founder john butterfield nonetheless
things started off decent in 1858 as
overland had a contract from the us
government but the problem was that this
was their primary source of revenue and
in 1859 when congress failed to pass the
annual post office appropriation bill
overland received no funding which led
them to take out even more debt from
wells fargo it didn't take long for
overland to become a default risk and in
1860 whilst fargo threatened to
foreclose on overland the founders of
overland didn't resist much and they
agreed to let wells fargo take over the
company but this didn't help much given
their dire situation
another express company that was founded
around the same time and facing a
similar issue called pony express would
actually shut down just six months later
so things were looking pretty sketchy
but luckily for wells fargo the us
government awarded overland a 1 million
express contract in 1861. wells fargo
hadn't even been around for 10 years yet
but somehow they had already received
their first bailout
despite the early encounter with
overland the next entry was pretty
smooth for wells fargo throughout the
rest of the 1800s wells fargo mainly
focused on growing its express business
which proved to be quite lucrative in
1869 for example wells fargo paid a
massive premium to acquire the pacific
union express company which gave them
exclusive rights to the central pacific
railroad for 10 years however this deal
also stipulated that the leader of
pacific union lord teves would take over
wells fargo as president
william fargo felt that this was a
beneficial trade for the company long
term under lloyd's leadership the
banking and express offices grew from
436 1871 to 3 500 by the end of the
century wells fargo also established
america's first transcontinental express
line which leveraged over a dozen
railroads this allowed them to expand
into the lucrative northeast market but
lloyd wasn't satisfied with just that he
also expanded the express service
internationally into japan australia
hong kong south america mexico and
europe on top of this lloyd also
expanded into the money order business
and wells fargo marched into the 1900s
full force
but the early 1900s wasn't that pleasant
for wells fargo due to external
circumstances
in 1906 san francisco was hit with an
earthquake that destroyed wells fargo's
national bank building the bank's vault
did survive but wells fargo was forced
to spend significant resources on
building back on the bright side
citizens and other businesses also spent
significant money on their own
properties which led to a massive influx
of capital within the next 18 months
wells fargo's deposits increased from 16
million dollars to 35 million
unfortunately though this didn't last
long as another banking panic came
around in 1997.
wells fargo didn't have any liquidity
problems but the panic was quite painful
as they lost 1 million worth of deposits
every week for 6 weeks straight this was
nothing though compared to what they
would lose in 1918. due to world war one
president wilson would approve the
nationalization of all express companies
so wells fargo was forced to give up
their express business
now you might be thinking that there
were more losses to come given that the
great depression was just around the
corner but this was actually not the
case the president of wells fargo at the
time frederick lipman was an extremely
conservative investor he chose to
reinvest all the bank's profits into
trust as opposed to the stock market so
wells fargo didn't even fuel the great
depression
in fact wells fargo helped bail out
failing institutions and their deposits
actually grew 2 million during the
banking holiday of 1933.
this teller performance earned wells
fargo unprecedented amounts of trust and
respect
wells fargo used all this new interest
to make loads of financial acquisitions
and by the 1970s they emerged as one of
the most dominant forces within the
banking industry
unfortunately though it didn't take long
for employees and executives to start
abusing this trust
in january of 1991 judith mclarty was
just completing one of her routine
audits at wells fargo when she uncovered
a 21.3 million hole in the records at
first most of the banking community
refused to believe it this must have
been some sort of error or mistake
there's no way wells fargo was linked to
any sort of fraud
just three months before this a top
auditing official named edward croak
proudly announced that wells fargo was
in an enviable position thanks to iron
fist on fraud and embezzlement yet here
they were it turns out that between 1978
and 1981 an employee named lord benjamin
lewis had been writing fake debit and
credit receipts to sam marshall who was
the president of muhammad ali
professional sports lloyd had used this
tactic to funnel out 21.3 million
dollars out of which he received 300 000
lloyd ended up playing guilty and
testifying against his co-conspirators
no executives were charged but it is a
bit suspicious that it took so long to
catch the fraud
it's not like lloyd was carrying out a
very sophisticated fraud either
something that we should note though is
that the ceo at the time richard cooley
did residentially after in 1982 despite
not being charged this poked the first
holes into wells fargo's reputation in a
hundred years and wells fargo's deposits
started to stagnate for the first time
in decades in order to make up for this
lower growth wells fargo played their
emphasis on acquisitions once again
in 1986 wells fargo purchased crocker
national bank for 1.1 billion dollars
and in 1988 they purchased barclays bank
of california for 125 million dollars
moving into the 1900s they considered a
merger with american express but this
fell through after the executives had a
disagreement
nonetheless wells fargo continued on in
their acquisition spree in 1996 they
purchased interstate bank corp for 11.6
billion dollars and in 1998 they merged
with norwest all these acquisitions
allowed wells fargo to continue their
rapid growth throughout the 80s and 90s
but there was no way they were going to
buy their way out of the dotcom crash
so like the rest of the banking industry
they tried to loan their way out and
that brings us into the 2000 financial
crisis
the 2008 financial recession really
needs no introduction and it was by no
means specific to wells fargo a large
number of banks got involved in risky
subprime mortgage lending which
eventually came to bite them back hard
as borrowers began to default massive
banks like lehman brothers and bear
stearns were taken down completely
following this the government panicked
and decided to bail out the remaining
banks which has since become one of the
most controversial decisions in history
wells fargo received a 25 billion
bailout and this permanently tarnished
reputation of the bank the silver lining
was that competitors like jp morgan
chase and bank of america also received
similar bailouts so the public outrage
wasn't just targeted at wells fargo
at this point it would have been best if
wells fargo just stayed out of the
spotlight and played it safe but instead
they decided to stage an ambitious
recovery the executives started putting
out impossible sales goals and ramped up
pressure to the max they had lost
decades of progress throughout the
recession and they were determined to
regain their losses but the problem was
that the sales goals were literally
impossible and desperate to meet the
sales goals many employees started to
fake numbers over the next several years
employees opened up 1.5 million checking
and savings accounts under their
customers names without their consent
they also opened up 500 000 credit cards
again without customers consent when
this canada was finally exposed in
september 2016 wells fargo lost all
credibility and i don't just mean
figuratively wells fargo literally lost
accreditation with the better business
bureau
on top of this they refined 185 million
dollars for the fiasco but this doesn't
really mean much given that they profit
roughly 20 billion dollars per year
wells fargo may have escaped serious
financial consequences but in terms of
reputation this was the final straw
applications for credit cards and
checking accounts fell off a cliff and
total assets have stagnated ever since
this might not sound that bad at first
glance but when you consider the rampant
inflation and the parabolic moves within
the real estate and stock markets this
is terrible
chase and the bank of america aren't
really liked either but both of them are
up about 50 in assets since 2016. so
really wells fargo is not stagnating
they're actually declining
to make things worse everything we've
discussed so far were just the biggest
scandals and frauds wells fargo has also
had plenty of smaller schemes as well
over the years they've been accused of
ignoring money laundering discriminating
against african americans and hispanic
borrowers violating credit card laws
committing insider trading lobbying and
rolling out predatory lending programs
considering all this i don't think
anyone is surprised by wells fargo's
high ranking on the most hated list
but you can't feel too bad given that
nearly all of it was self-inflicted
looking forward wells fargo may not have
much longer almost everyone agrees that
given the ludicrous debt levels a great
deleveraging is inevitable ray dalio has
been preaching this for years and
recently even elon musk jumped on board
and given that wells fargo is already on
a decline they may get wiped out by this
upcoming storm just like lehman brothers
who knows though wells fargo crushed the
great depression so maybe they'll
surprise everyone and crush the grade
deleveraging it as well but we'll just
have to wait and see
do you guys think wells fargo will cross
the grady leveraging or get crushed
themselves comment that down below
also drop a like if you're not a fan of
big banks and of course consider joining
our discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing and
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you